so in the middle of this obviously we
here at daily wire had been uh
foraying into the film industry we had
released our first film a little bit
earlier this year run hide fight
our audience really loved it and when we
saw that you were trending
um my business partner jeremy and i
we thought the first thing we thought
was number one somebody should reach out
to gina because she's
getting maligned unfairly um but number
two we should reach out to gina because
this is an opportunity for
conservatives and people who think
differently to say to hollywood that
you're not allowed to just cancel
whomever you want and uh
i mean i have to say that i was amazed
at how readily you were willing to jump
into
a project with derelicts like us
and willing to get involved in in one of
our projects
because it is a unique thing i mean in
hollywood typically the advice is keep
your head down
make an apology maybe in three four
years you can sort of weedle your way
back into the industry but you didn't do
any of that you were
basically ready to go from the moment i
gave you a call i wanted to get your
perspective on that
well because you know and my newfound
you know finding my political
uh voice you you're actually one of the
people i found
um as as well as a bunch you're actually
you're your book was the first one i
read
um and it just really kind of it was so
it was so
simple that it really kind of explained
like the events in such a
you know in such a good way to where
it was like it just felt logical it felt
logical um
and um
so i i'm obviously like so excited that
you called i
i was you know i was prepared
to at any point get let go because i've
seen
this happen to so many people um
you know i've seen the looks on their
faces i've
seen the bullying that takes place
they've quit twitter
you know they've quit speaking they show
up to their red carpets and they're
depressed and they're sad and
there's hard hearts there and i was like
you're gonna you're you're coming for me
i know you are
it's not a they're making it very
obvious through their
employees that were coming for me and so
i was like well
well then i'm gonna go i'm gonna go down
swinging then
and i'm gonna stay true to myself and
i'm gonna let that speak
and um i think that's speaking so
when you called i you know i'm still
like
my body still is shaking you know
it's still devastating um
but the thought of
this happening to anybody else
especially like somebody who could not
handle this
the way i can no
they don't get to do that they don't get
to make people feel like that
and if i buckle them then
little girls and little boys who are not
getting any rep
like they're not getting a good fair
shake at growing up right now
if i buckle it's gonna make it okay for
these companies who have a history of
lying
to beeline and to do this to other
people and they've done it to other
people
and um
and i'm not going down without a fight
well we couldn't be more excited to be
working with you obviously and uh and
you can see that the
the left is creating a whole new cottage
industry for us because as they keep
canceling people for no good reason we
are perfectly happy to work with
talented people
of every stripe uh especially after the
left decides that uh they are terrible
bites into having differing points
of view so i want to backtrack here a
little bit and talk about
uh how you even got into acting in the
first place because
you have the most unique acting story
that i know i mean
you started by hitting people in the
face so why don't we start
when we start with that like how did
when
when people think actress typically they
don't think a person who used to be an
mma fighter so first and when they think
mma fighter they don't tend to think
female
generally so you were the first big
female mma star in america
how did you get into mma that's sort of
the unique career path
oh well definitely not by my family's
approval
my my family actually did everything
they could to make sure that that
first uh sanctioned fight in las vegas
for a female women's
mma match did not happen and um
and so i was having to go through all
these extra tests and i found out like
my
who i love you so much my papa don who
passed away
and my dad who's still around uh had
called the athletic commission and my
dad used to serve on the athletic
commission so
they were you know so i was going
through some extra tests because he did
not
want me to be a fighter they wanted me
to you know really go to school
and uh become a doctor a lawyer and
you know my family's the type of family
on both sides you know you're not
getting any of that you're not getting
anything for free
you earn your keep you're responsible
and you get out there and you work
and so um i was like okay that's what
i'm doing
and i don't like money being hung over
my head ever so
uh this is just something fighting was
just something that spoke to me you know
like it just made me want to get in the
gym it made me
i was good at it i've been in fights so
many times in las vegas anyways never
that i started
um i was always like defending people
it's like
i am able to walk away from a fight but
when i realize that has something to do
with somebody else
and i have a like there's this hot blood
that goes through me
and then and then things happen
um but so yeah i just started fighting
and um
i loved it it's like all the bad things
i was doing and all the
i've had friends shot in the head and
left in the desert i have been
stabbed in head and left in the desert
in las vegas um
you know overdoses and the whole story
of like this tragic thing and i didn't
i was like okay why don't you just try
try to give life a chance
and i started training and fighting and
it just became
my new addiction and from the moment i
started doing it everybody was pointing
a camera at me
i was like i'm actually extremely shy
i'm actually like it's hard for me you
know performing or talking and having
things
but um i think i'm getting a little bit
better at it
so i will admit although you probably
couldn't tell
being that i am such an adonis like
figure i mean it's just an
amazing greek god of masculine power
i'm not a person who's done a lot of
fighting as you you maybe you might have
guessed that i don't know
but yeah no most people picked up on
that
in any case what is it like to be a
professional fighter what is it like
that's always been fascinating to me
because as somebody who
uh you know went to jewish day school
and basically fights consisted
of people you know randomly wailing on
each other without any sort of real form
or
anything let's put this way no one from
my jewish day school ended up as a
professional fighter
so what is it like being a professional
fighter what's it like walking into a
ring and knowing that you have to beat
the hell out of somebody else in order
to
in order to win well i think it starts
in walking into a gym
and the most beautiful thing about
walking into a mixed martial arts gym
is it doesn't matter what color you are
what religion you are if you're a cop or
if you're not
it doesn't matter who you are you get
into that gym and you start training
together and
it's the full it's everybody in that gym
and you know you get humbled every
single day
and then you learn how to like be a part
of a team and then you start
taking care of each other and then you
start seeing i mean you see all the
weaknesses of like you know the ego
flare-ups and then like you know wait
okay so you know you really have to
balance your ego
in an mma gym because if your ego gets
ahead of you like that's a weakness
um so like i love that
i love genuine and i love real human
beings
and so that was like a place of like
everybody in this you know everybody
belongs here
and the fighting part that was that was
hard
but uh there's nothing like facing a
fear
um you know and it's very intimate it's
like
i'm attracted to intimacy as well
so i when you look across um
a ring and you're looking at that
person's eyes you know
this is all about to get very real and
it's only going to be
me and you and there's going to be a
genuine interaction
and i crave those kinds of things that
was addicting to me did you have to
learn to take a punch i mean how does
that work
as somebody who has full-time security i
will never have to deal with this
i don't know i just since i had been in
fights growing up
i uh i have an incredible
i have an incredible chin
i'm like like my nose i i think you know
it's
it just like it takes uh if i bleed you
know
i'm hurting because i'm not a bleeder
and my chin is just good
so i i have this special little talent
that i have
um i hit pretty hard
and uh like i've been comp
like i've been very complimented on how
hard i can hit
um and so uh
i just i became addicted to it and i
still have a little bit of an
addiction to it i still do mma in in
your
my my whole garage is like my whole life
i have so many friends that are fighters
and
you know they're so real like you point
a camera at them and it's like
effortless
because they they don't they haven't
sold themselves
you know but they haven't sold
themselves
they they own themselves and they know
that they're going to take themselves
into battle against another person
and um and i like that as well
like being a part of hollywood you know
people are stabbing you in the back left
and right and people are willing to cut
your throat just to get another job and
you're like whoa
like i've never been that way i'm never
gonna actually i've
when i did american gladiators
we were doing the jousting thing and i
took down this girl the bigger girl
i took her down um and
it was her dream to be american
gladiator right like she wanted to be an
american gladiator and like i took her
down in like two shots and like you know
then she ran to the bathroom and started
crying and i realized at the moment i
was like oh my
i am not going to take this job away
from her like we're doing tryouts right
now and i just knocked her off of that
and i'm not really super passionate
about being like putting spandex anyway
so i was like
you know and so like i kind of just like
exited like the tryouts and i jumped in
my impala
and i drove driving back to vegas from
la
and then producers were calling me up
and they always yeah i keep in touch
with them sometimes and they're like
aren't you glad we made you do that but
like
and i i got on the i finally picked up
and the producer was like
he's like gina please come back and i
was like
no no man like i'm not about to take
that job away from that woman she wants
to be there
i don't care if i'm there i'm not going
to cut and they're like
what helga no we love her and i was like
okay but i still don't really want to do
it
and it took them four phone calls in
order to for me to like
you know i showed up the day of filming
and they hadn't even got an outfit for
me and i showed up and like
they ended up using me for almost
everything like physical like the
wrestling and the pyramid and everything
because um you know just because you got
muscles doesn't mean you'd be so
athletic so
i was it was such a fun job and i'm glad
i did it so
what is your sort of daily workout
regimen like now
um well for the last week it was a
little bit of crying in bed
i mean i do want people to know that you
know
this this has not been easy
and i think you know i have i'm a human
being i have so much
to learn and grow and i am um
i am deeply understanding um it's like
the
curtains got pulled and i'm seeing so
much
and um so that's been a very
large realization so i do think when
this does happen to people it's like
you know being canceled might become
trendy one day
um but don't think that when it happens
to you it's going to be easy
because it's not it's going to be maybe
possibly one of the hardest things
that you've ever been through but i
think you know
each day that goes by you kind of stand
up and you
find your legs again and you stop
feeling sorry for yourself
and you you show up you show up to an
awesome
opportunity with people who want
you to sit at their table you know
i think it was nina simone that said
something along the lines of you need to
understand
when love is no longer being served at
the table
so you need to understand when to leave
and
okay i'm not going to shove my self down
anybody's throats
we disagreed it didn't go well 2020 was
a very emotional year for a lot of
people
um okay i'll get up and find another
table
and hopefully invite more people to that
because i'm about love
and real true diversity what was it like
to move from mma into hollywood how did
that transition actually happen
so moving from la to hollywood i had
just lost the biggest fight of my life
which that was another time where i was
kind of feeling like
staying in bed for some controversy
around that fight now with regard to
the person who you were fighting oh
cyborg um are you talking about
steroids yes yeah um you know
it's not my job to go point in the
fingers at her so
i you know i take the loss i'll take it
on the chin i'll take the loss because
what happened to me
the next week was um kind of similar to
the situation like
you showed up when i needed somebody
when i was in
just hurt mode and when i was in hurt
mode
uh steven soderbergh showed up but i
didn't know what that was at the time
and he said you know they like oh you
know
steven sodeberg wants to have a
conversation with you and i'm like who's
that
and then um we had a beautiful
conversation and he said okay well this
is going to happen
really quick or not at all and it
happened and
then i had then i found a new something
tricky and new because i
being an athlete it's like you always
have to be yourself out in front of
everybody
um and i've always been really attracted
to art because i think art really does
change the world you know
i love art i love putting out things
where it's like think about it
and everybody sees it differently that's
my favorite everybody feels it
differently and everybody finds
different
movies and shows and art and like they
find them at different points in their
life and it's their expression of who
they are i love that and so here's my
opportunity because i cannot paint
and you know like so i found an art that
i dove into
and um yeah that
that's not been easy sometimes i think
it was a little bit easier getting
punched in the face
at least you didn't see the knife coming
through your back
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets
in the country if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and subscribe
to our youtube channel so you don't miss
out on any of our content